she's
a no emotion little girl
are they dead
does it matter everybody knows a lot of
people like that
showtime she doesn't show lots of
happiness or she doesn't show you when
she's sad except for maybe she'll crack
a little smile sometimes or she'll give
you a little evil grin but that's pretty
much it she's scheming she loves to be
suspicious of people may i have the salt
what do we say
[Music]
now
well the hard thing for me is the food
because we had a couple of breakfast
scenes and you just look at this food
and you go
um
where's your costume this is my costume
i'm a homicidal maniac they look just
like everyone else
what do your friends say when they find
out that you're playing in this movie
well mainly they just go around humming
the theme song for a while the adam's
family
because when i first told them everybody
everybody started hearing about it and
they kept humming the theme song kind of
annoying me
don't torture yourself gomez
that's my job
well i read the script and i thought it
was very well written and it was a lot
of fun very much like a family kind of
atmosphere
except that they are very weird crazy
bizarre
humorous and human at the same time look
at her
i would die for her
i would kill for her
either way one bliss i see it sort of
like that people are people no matter
what and no matter how they dress no
matter how they live people are people
and human beings are human beings and
beyond the fun and games and all that
there's a kind of message that says you
know weird looking people are human
beings too then you'll see in the addams
family that these people are very warm
and they're very loving and and and
they're real human beings in spite of
their weirdness leather straps
red hot pokers
later my dearest
and he starts dancing
[Music]
[Applause]
okay let's try that again
[Music]
the brothers karamazov and the german
brothers grim there's orville wright and
wilbur always nothing minus him
[Music]
you've been practicing
[Music]